tout petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauver secourir protéger finalement j'ai
changé de cap je suis journaliste et
j'ai décidé d'aller à la rencontre de
ces hommes et de ses femmes ordinaires
qui vivent des expériences hors du
commun
si je prends un verre après savoir
partir
me voilà dans le seul hôpital public de
France spécialisé dans le traitement des
addictions et principalement de
l'alcoolisme
vas-y je vais chercher un kebab et puis
je rentre à 7h du mat le lendemain
pieds
maintenant avec ma femme
vous allez faire comment puisque vous
êtes dépendants il va falloir faire le
deuil de l'alcool je pense qu'il est pas
fait encore en gros pourquoi ils boivent
les gens ça
dépend
je vais passer une semaine avec un
groupe d'hommes nous aide aux femmes qui
se battent avec le même espoir
vaincre leur addiction à l'alcool
j'ai rencontré Cédric il a tout perdu il
est ici pour regagner la confiance de sa
femme et de son fils
je ferai la connaissance de Didier il va
mieux et prépare sa sortie
[Musique]
Benoît m'a particulièrement ému naïf il
rêve d'une cure rapide
j'ai croisé une centaine de patients je
ne sais pas combien sortir en guéri et
combien rechuteront
[Musique]
parmi toutes les addictions celles qui
touche le plus les Français c'est
l'alcoolisme certes la consommation
baisse depuis 30 ans mais le nombre de
personnes dépendantes restent stable
[Musique]
je vais passer quelques jours dans ce
centre spécialisé l'hôpital Louis
Sauvestre dans la banlieue de Tours un
lieu unique en France ici depuis 1961 on
traite exclusivement des malades
souffrant de dépendance au sexe au jeu
aux drogues mais surtout à l'alcool
[Musique]
le centre dispose de 140 lits il
accueille un millier de patients par an
pour des cures de trois mois quelques
femmes mais surtout des hommes qui
viennent de toute la France
bonjour bonjour tout le monde ça va bien
je suis accueilli par un petit groupe de
patients ils sont sur le point de
commencer leur journée de soins
et fumer plus de clopes
première semaine j'avais mal à la vessie
tellement je buvais du café
dans les deux cas je sais pas comment ça
va se passer
mes enfants
oui
5 7 8 et 17
tout ce que tu fais là c'est pour oui
totalement je vous laisse messieurs bon
courage
à vous
toi aussi
dès leur arrivée à l'hôpital les malades
des signes un contrat thérapeutique il
s'engage à prendre leurs médicaments
à participer à des groupes de parole les
gens d'exclus forcément
et à travailler dans des ateliers
manuels ne pas respecter l'une de ces
trois règles entraîne l'exclusion
immédiate
à lui sovestre tout est mis en oeuvre
pour en finir avec l'alcool en trois
mois Anne et l'une des psychologues de
l'hôpital
bonjour vous allez bien
Anne travaille dans l'établissement
depuis deux ans
c'est bête la question que je vais vous
poser là tout de suite mais en gros
pourquoi il boit que les gens ça
dépend de
passer c'est qu'il y a une émotion qui
suggère qui submerge l'individu qui est
incapable de gérer et qu'il va remplacer
par une sensation qui est la sensation
de vide que procure l'alcool chance de
se sortir de la dépendance alcoolique si
on identifie pas la
source du mal quoi il faut comprendre
comment à quoi sert l'alcool à quoi sert
l'alcool donc ça veut dire qu'il y a un
moment il faut se poser les bonnes
questions et le travail qui est fait
c'est
identifier effectivement comment
fonctionne avec l'alcool et puis creuser
la motivation mais trouver au fond de
soi la ressource nécessaire pour ne plus
succomber à la tentation beaucoup ont
essayé après plusieurs cuirs de dire bon
allez je vais essayer de contrôler c'est
juste pour les anniversaires ou juste
pour Noël et c'est reparti à chaque fois
les consommations sont encore plus
massives d'ailleurs comme s'il y avait
un rattrapage en fait de ce qui avait
été une période d'abstinence donc non il
y a pas de possibilité de contrôle ce
sont des gens qui se font happer par le
produit quoi
bonjour et merci de nous autoriser à
filmer votre entretien
didier est hospitalisé depuis un mois et
demi il est à mi parcours de son
traitement et il a rendez-vous avec Anne
pour faire le point mettez-vous à l'aise
maintenant c'est long maintenant c'est
plus des pulsions j'y pense j'y pense ça
allait être motivant dans ma tête je me
dis je peux donc c'est facile mais
en fait je me dis que je peux je me dis
que c'est facile mais je me dis c'est
pas la peine quoi j'ai pas fait tout ce
chemin pour retomber d'où je viens c'est
pas utile donc voilà donc je mets à
profit tout ce qu'on fait ici pour
justement passer passer par au-dessus et
avancer vers le mieux
Didier commence à ressentir les effets
bénéfiques de sa cure mais il a encore
un bout de chemin à faire
c'est votre récompense vous méritez
d'être heureux vous méritez d'aller bien
c'est ce que je me dis maintenant
vous pensiez
moi les choses c'était moi optimiste moi
moins détendu mentalement ça me fait du
bien beaucoup plus détendu qu'avant
effectivement
prenez le temps vous prenez le temps de
de vivre le présent de pas être sans
arrêt dans la fuite ou courir après
quelque chose et vous êtes en trois mois
une relation forte a le temps de
s'installer entre la thérapeute et son
patient mon but c'est l'abscinant c'est
une abscissant heureuse quoi ça je le
revendique quoi c'est à dire que voilà
je tiens pas je tiens pas ce que soit
une contrainte
c'est ça c'est sûr ça peut pas tenir ça
c'est une contrainte continue toujours à
ce travail par rapport à ce qui s'est ce
qui était l'alcool avant
fin de journée et puis je vous envoie la
semaine prochaine OK
au bout de 45 minutes Didier s'en va
mais moi je reste j'ai besoin d'en
savoir plus je veux comprendre à quel
moment un alcoolique décroche vraiment
quand les les patients ont terminé leur
cure et sans vous est-ce que vous vous
savez
si ça a marché ou s'ils vont rechuter ça
dépend des personnes
un des signes c'est
cette capacité justement de
d'auto observation et de lucidité par
rapport à son sa manière de se comporter
par rapport à l'alcool les personnes
disent moi c'est bon j'ai compris c'est
réglé l'alcool c'est fini c'est entre
plus dans ma vie attention c'est normal
pendant 15 ans à chaque fois qu'ils ont
eu peur à chaque fois que il y a une
angoisse il y avait l'alcool parce qu'on
aurait fait une cure d'un seul coup paf
l'alcool disparaît bah non ça c'est un
leur
[Musique]
à Louis Sevestre il arrive tous les
jours de nouveaux patients
Jean-François est infirmier ici depuis 8
ans
bonjour
sa journée commence par un bilan de la
nuit
il y a eu l'entrée de 22h qui arrivait à
21h40 qui était donc à 0,24
parce qu'il voulait pas réveiller ceux
d'à côté
[Musique]
je vais devoir me suivre
le premier contact avec un nouvel
arrivant est essentiel il faut la jouer
en douceur
je suis infirmier de ce matin
vous allez bien ça va bien dormi
avec la télé toute la journée toute la
nuit quand même
je peux voir un peu les volets oui
donc vous êtes arrivés tard hier soir
c'est ça oui je suis arrivé à Tours
de prendre le taxi puis arrivé là ça me
fait quoi à peu près 9h30 donc vous
sentez capable d'aller prendre le petit
déj en bas là
donc là c'est là où vous avez demandé à
rester trois mois c'est ça
il surpris Benoît est bien pressé
pourtant ici les cures sont de 3 mois en
immersion totale en attendant de mieux
comprendre ses motivations direction la
salle à manger donc le petit déj
biscotte pain confiture enfin vous allez
voir c'est le luxe
[Musique]
pour son premier repas Benoît s'assoit à
la table d'un patient dont la cure
s'achève
en plus de son addiction à l'alcool
Gilles souffre d'une insuffisance
respiratoire liée à une maladie
professionnelle il vit accroché à sa
bonbonne d'oxygène les autres patients
le surnomme Butagaz
c'est son dernier jour à l'hôpital
à la journée de la
[Musique]
ça va très vite on croit que c'est long
mais ça va assez
je suis arrivé hier soir à 9h30
à 9h02 taxi puis de venir là-bas ça m'a
fait à peu près 9h30
Gilles le vétéran va donner à Benoît les
clés d'un séjour réussi parole de
presque spécialiste
[Musique]
au maximum d'activités maximum
d'activités
rares sont les patients qui décrochent
en une seule cure il faut souvent
revenir plusieurs fois les médecins
disent même que les rechutes font partie
de la thérapie Gilles a fait sa première
culinée à un an après six mois
d'abstinence il a replongé pour lui
cette fois c'est la bonne il tient à
nous montrer de vieux souvenirs alors
voilà le
la différence qu'il y a vous avez vu
c'est que l'alcool peut arriver
et quand on arrive à prendre conscience
de ça on se dit quand même que
c'est affreux
depuis toujours moi j'ai commencé les
chantiers en faisant les déplacements
avec mon père je mets 15 ans et demi
donc j'ai vécu ma jeunesse un petit peu
avec des gens beaucoup plus âgés que moi
puis je fais comme les autres
puis après j'ai fait l'homme
puis après j'ai continué à faire l'homme
et puis après derrière il a fait chier
son alcoolisme
[Musique]
un étage au-dessus Benoît le petit
nouveau découvre sa chambre avec
Jean-François son infirmier référent
voilà vos appartements
donc voilà votre armoire d'accord et
Jean-François
vérifie le contenu des bagages de Benoît
illicite
je vous laisse déballer vos affaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un petit couteau je le prends là
on enlève tout ce qui est tranchant
parce que forcément il y a des gens qui
sont un petit peu soit dépressifs donc
il y a des gens qui
arrivent à se faire du mal
avec soi un couteau sur un canifon de
non pas trop mais tout ce qui est même
qui c'est une petite lame comme ça ça
coupe ça peut
quand même parce que c'est bon c'est la
production comment est-ce que c'est bon
le produit le produit c'est du baume
après-rasage ouais par rapport à quoi
vous me dites
du gel de façon vous consommez vous
consommez pas de parfum pas de choses
comme ça vous buvez pas de parfum ou non
non non non
il y a pas de problème toute façon si on
a un doute ou quoi de toute façon vous
le verrez bien on le voit et puis on
vérifie on fait un étiothèse
ça peut être n'importe quand n'importe
quel moment
j'en ai eu hier soir mais effectivement
il y a des gens qui viennent ici qui
viennent ici avec
avec soit des bières dans le sac ou quoi
et puis qui s'attendent pas non plus
forcément à ce qu'on fasse une fouille
pour pas être c'est vous qui avez décidé
de venir monsieur
c'est vous qui avez décidé de venir ici
à cabri mais bon ça fait quand même 6
ans je vois pas mes enfants je vois
quand même bien essayer de m'en sortir
parce que bon si je perds mon boulot
mais après j'ai plus de j'ai plus rien
avant de quitter l'hôpital les patients
ont un dernier entretien de sortie
monsieur monsieur là
devant son médecin référent Gilles
évoque ses projets à venir et surtout
confirme sa décision d'arrêter de boire
ça y est c'est le grand départ donc
l'idée
mon comportement c'est que quand je veux
arriver les gens
je vous souhaite vraiment plein de
bonnes choses pour la suite et moi aussi
le cœur et puis bah je vous remercie de
votre gentillesse
et de
[Applaudissements]
d'abord
vous avez fait quand même le plus gros
du travail donc on vous a épaulé sur ce
chemin là
[Musique]
Gilles salut c'est complices de galère
dans quelques minutes il sera seul face
à la tentation
[Musique]
ici monsieur
ça y est c'est le grand saut sans
médecin sans psychologue
[Musique]
pour tromper le manque ne pas penser à
l'alcool il faut s'occuper retrouver une
activité physique des horaires une
discipline couture jardinage arts
plastiques blanchisserie
ces ateliers font partie de la cure dans
l'atelier bois les patients fabriquent
des objets de décoration ils sont hyper
concentrés il vaut mieux certaines
machines sont dangereuses
ça permet vraiment de tout faire ce truc
là ça fait une scie à chantourner un
champion
c'est vrai que ça c'est très intéressant
c'est reposant
on évite de penser à beaucoup de choses
c'est à dire bien évidemment
l'alcool et tout ça et puis voilà ça
permet d'être au calme maintenant vous
buvez quoi
principalement café j'en ai un peu marre
alors je me suis mioté c'est vrai c'est
vrai je fréquente les salons de thé
maintenant avec ma femme
mais ça n'empêche pas d'aller au bar
weekend dernier je suis allé au bar
rencontré deux trois potes bon bah j'ai
pris un invité le frais avis tellement
puis voilà terminé
il me pose pas la question
je vous laisse finir ouais merci
bonne journée bonne journée
[Applaudissements]
à l'atelier bois les patients
réapprennent à être minutieux et
préparant en quelque sorte leur retour à
la vie professionnelle
tout à fait tout à fait parce que ça
nous met dans un certain concentration
de nous-mêmes et de voilà ça nous
apprend à avoir des gestes bien précis
pas trop la tremblotte mais non
justement c'est grâce à ça que mes
tremblements ont disparu parce que ben
oui on est là on s'efforce vraiment à
retrouver justement la précision du jeu
de la précision du geste et voilà et je
pense que les pâtes caché du coup
vraiment limite quoi j'ai diminué mon
traitement de moitié depuis que je suis
à cet atelier quoi ces alcooliques
abstinents ont l'air heureux ici dans
cet atelier l'ambiance est zen apaisée
certitude absolue que c'est fini tout ça
on peut jamais dire
je suis sûr je l'ai appris
c'est ma sixième cure
mais
c'est ce que j'avais fait auparavant
c'était des Kurdes trois semaines un
maximum ça a été un mois
[Musique]
on n'a pas assez d'outils quand on sort
aider les malades à constituer leur
propre boîte à outils c'est l'une des
priorités de l'équipe soignante
aujourd'hui Cédric fait un point avec
Jean-François son infirmière référent il
est arrivé il y a deux semaines
c'est parti l'alcool lui a tout pris
femme enfant travaille à 38 ans il a
tout perdu
[Musique]
chercher l'aspect au début
voilà apaisant relaxant
puis pour oublier un petit peu tous les
tracas de la vie quoi avec la séparation
alors là c'est encore plus facile je
buvais
un poison donc séparation justement dû à
l'alcool d'accord oui parce que bon elle
pouvait plus tenir chasse
occupé de de mon fils plus
l'inquiétude tous les soirs vas-y je
vais chercher un kebab et puis je rentre
à 7h du mat le lendemain
pieds des histoires comme ça ou alors
fallait me revenir me chercher au
commissariat je suis venu là ici pour
récupérer mon fils pour avoir la garde
justement à force d'être sous forcément
me le laissez pas
Cédric fait fausse route ça n'est pas
pour son fils qu'il doit se soigner mais
pour lui c'est à ce prix que ça marche
moi j'ai toujours connu mon petit single
Malte mon bon
Bourgogne
une bonne bière belge vous avez un
regard illuminé comme parler de ça
va falloir faire le deuil de l'alcool je
pense qu'il est pas fait encore
j'insiste
là dessus
moi je me demandais ce qui vous arrivait
si
si vous n'obteniez pas la garde alternée
c'est le jeu joue la donne pas parce que
il y a mille raisons pour pas vous la
donner même si vous avez fait une cure
le passé est lourd donc de coup le juge
peut-être il va pas vous la donner en
tout cas pas au premier coup
[Musique]
craquer un soir par exemple le lendemain
quand vous allez vous réveiller vous
allez faire quoi
je n'imagine pas revenir en cure donc
j'ai pas envie de refaire un sevrage
vous savez que vous êtes dépendant donc
quelqu'un qui n'est pas alcool au
dépendant
le lendemain il a pas de mal à ne pas
boire mais vous
vous allez faire comment puisque vous
êtes dépendants
Jean-François vient de marquer un point
son patient entrevoit maintenant la
conduite à tenir si vous ras alcoolisez
une fois faut surtout pas vous
culpabilisez pas vous dire ça y est j'ai
fait des cures et des cures ça sert à
rien je suis un bon à rien
si vous réagissez tout de suite
ce sera un simple faux pas qui sera même
peut-être salvateur pour la suite le
travail de Cédric ne fait que commencer
[Musique]
ça a l'air simple comme ça mais c'est en
fait comme c'est doublé de problèmes
sociaux de tous les côtés évidemment si
ça a été qu'une question de volonté de
l'alcool mais tout autour
du travail assumer un divorce obtenir la
garde alternée
déménager
monter toute une série d'activités et
là-dessus ne pas ne pas boire à nouveau
c'est ils sont forts c'est presque
insurmontable
ça m'a fait beaucoup de mal
à moi et à ma famille je vais arriver
ici en me disant que j'allais pas mentir
pour lui ce serait dommage de tout le
foot en l'air parce que
une nouvelle addiction ouais c'est une
bonne addiction mais faites gaffe quand
même nous sommes très très défavorables
à ce que les couples se forment à
l'intérieur de l'établissement jour
partir de là
[Musique]
une fois par semaine les patients
peuvent rencontrer d'anciens alcooliques
investis dans des associations
aujourd'hui la section locale d'alcool
assistance
en Indre-et-Loire donc avec moi
Jean-Claude de Jean-Claude Couratin j'ai
fait ma cure ici
et depuis ce temps-là ça baigne
Jean-Claude et Guy tend de la main aux
alcooliques comme on l'a fait pour eux
il y a plus de 10 ans
ils viennent transmettre leur véhicule
pour encourager des malades à partager
leurs épreuves
la première réunion où je suis allé mais
je vais me retrouver mais je vais me
retrouver avec des gens qui vont être
rouge qui doit être le clochard et tout
enfin honnêtement je le dis c'est ça et
c'est cette image là qu'on avait du
malade alcoolique à quelqu'un qui est
délabré qui qui mal foutu et tout quoi
c'est ça et puis et puis ça touche tout
le monde
qu'à moi personnel j'étais quand même
rendu ce qui est grave à me réveiller en
pleine nuit c'était donc boire une nuit
de 6 fumer ma cigarette voir le petit
pétard à côté et de dos le téléphone je
vais m'en occuper plus
je répondais plus au téléphone et je me
réveillais c'était le coeur qui
palpitait hop je rebuvait j'allais me
recoucher je rebuvait j'allais me
recoucher faites ma vie elle était basée
que sur ça on sortait plus on s'oxygène
plus donc on prend plus l'air l'air
c'est important de sortir dehors tous
les jours au moins faire une demi-heure
de marche voilà c'est comme moi la fin
c'était pas motivé
à la maison je voulais de faire
certaines choses
en finir avec l'alcool implique un
réaménagement complet de sa vie à la fin
de la cure on n'est pas sortis
d'affaires au niveau de l'archute
moi je
pense que c'est un mal nécessaire pour
certains oui
parce que bien souvent il y a des gens
qui perdent d'ici vachement confiants
j'ai pigé je bois plus c'est terminé on
a pas le peu et puis j'ai rien compris
au film ce qu'il y a faut pas trop vous
avancer il faut y aller mollo dans ce
que vous allez faire en sortant savoir
que ça bouton ça vous prévient pas ça
vous tombera dessus comme ça même moi je
sais que oui ça fait 10 ans et même
encore je suis vigilant parce que je
sais très bien que
on est quoi ce serait dommage de te
[ __ ] en l'herbe avec un petit verre
d'alcool
même une six mois ce serait que faut
être complètement con
je risque de replonger tout ça ça fait
peur quand même quelque part je vais
vivre avec tout le temps dans la tête
l'idée que je peux craquer même on vous
disant quoi moi je sais pas je suis
arrivé ici quand j'entendais parler de
rechute je me suis demandé ce que je
suis venu au foot
ici je suis revenu ici si je passe trois
mois ici et puis si c'est pour revenir
dans 6 mois ou dans deux ans je propose
rien
Jean-Claude prêche l'abstinence depuis
10 ans il s'est trouvé les mots et aux
besoins détendre l'atmosphère
j'habitais avant il y avait il y avait
une fête c'était la fête de la
Saint-Jean il avait c'était des amis qui
nous organisaient et il y avait
entrecôterie avec le bal et tout le
tralala et puis bon j'étais un bon
danseur il y a une copine qui m'aime
trouver qui me dit papy tu vas me faire
dans la chatte en gros
avec toi qu'avant et puis pourquoi dans
ce mal elle me dit non tu fais plus de
la gueule
ça fait plaisir
bon
j'espère qu'on vous a pas trop ennuyé
n'hésitez pas prenez nos coordonnées et
merci
incroyable
toute la journée ils prennent la parole
pour raconter leur histoire ils se
retrouvait avec une asseau et tout le
monde reprend la parole c'est incroyable
sans doute ce besoin que vous avez de
parler pour à nouveau prendre la parole
là vous voyez des petits voyez des
psychiatres des infirmiers et à nouveau
là re- raconter sa vie oui parce que
quand on voit notre
psychologue ou votre médecin c'est en
privé le fait de ça en fait ça peut
faire partie c'est un déclic à d'autres
personnes la parole qui a été donnée qui
a été dite
peuvent à une personne dire tiens bah
moi effectivement je suis d'accord avec
qui a été dit là tu me demandes si elle
est pas bien parti pour être un jour
responsable de votre association la dame
tout à fait tout à fait
vous aimeriez pas faire ça je suis sûr
que oui
je suis aide-soignante
voilà
femme sociable a fonctionné
bonne fin de journée à vous merci au
revoir merci
tout à fait
lui c'est Cyril avec son stylo et ses
classeurs il a tout d'un travailleur
social mais c'est un patient en cure
depuis deux mois il participe à un
atelier thérapeutique qui consiste à
prendre en charge un malade qui vient
d'arriver en l'occurrence Benoît
bonjour bonjour Cyril
donc je suis là pour vous accueillir oui
on va on va passer deux jours ensemble
je vais vous montrer un peu le
fonctionnement
l'établissement
voilà à 11h15
allez c'est parti let's go
[Musique]
Cyril va apprendre à Benoît comment se
repérer dans les longs couloirs de
l'établissement
[Musique]
donc là je te laisse je te laisse avec
le docteur Husson
pour l'instant d'accord on fait comme ça
on fait comme ça ça marche
le docteur Husson est la médecin
psychiatre spécialisée en addictologie
qui va suivre Benoît tout au long de sa
cure il se rend compte pour la première
fois
[Applaudissements]
au niveau de la famille vos parents sont
toujours en vie monsieur
conducteur poids lourd est-ce qu'il
avait des problèmes d'alcool papa
un petit peu
c'est-à-dire
comment un petit peu buvait comment
normal
avec ces questions anodines le docteur
Husson dresse un premier profil de son
patient pour mettre en place le
traitement vous êtes marié divorcé
c'est vous qui avez demandé qu'à son âge
et c'est elle qui est parti
avec les enfants bah oui c'est logique
actuellement vous êtes seul
non vous avez une amie
avec qui ça se passe pas très bien
[Musique]
c'est une amie que vous avez rencontré
sur internet
il faut maintenant cerner la relation
que Benoît entretient avec l'alcool
l'addictologue avance délicatement car
elle le sont fragiles
sous alcool comment vous êtes est-ce que
vous êtes plutôt violent non c'est tout
le contraire vous êtes comment toujours
[Musique]
le docteur Husson cherche maintenant à
comprendre les motivations de Benoît je
repartir de là
pourquoi parce que c'est si je prends un
verre après avoir partir oui
[Musique]
prochain rendez-vous dans une semaine ou
avant si nécessaire
[Musique]
pendant ce temps-là à la cantine de
l'hôpital un événement vient rompre la
routine ça fait jaser les résidents deux
patients sont tombés amoureux
vous pouvez venir vous installer à notre
table
Isabelle et Frédéric sont arrivés la
même semaine
il y a un mois depuis deux jours il ne
se quitte plus
addiction
nous avons une nouvelle addiction ouais
c'est une bonne addiction mais faites
gaffe quand même mais écoute si chaque
personne dans un centre trouvé la petite
chose qui qui bonheur qui peut fait que
ben voilà tu retournes pas de temps je
trouve ça bien quoi oui pourquoi pas
après faut voir l'extérieur il y a une
chose qui est vachement plus simple
aussi entre nous c'est que on a la même
addict on est venu ici pour la même
addiction donc oui bon déjà ça peut être
aussi plus facile à l'extérieur après
pas forcément oui mais ça peut l'être je
dis pas forcément le problème c'est que
les médecins ne sont pas de cet avis
des rapports parce qu'ils ont peur que
vous prenez pas soin de vous les
rapports je te parle pas de rapport
humain voilà
quelques heures plus tard le docteur
Husson convoque l'un des deux
tourtereaux
l'équipe médicale en charge de Frédéric
est présente la psychiatre veut faire un
point avec son patient et le recadrer
vous entretenez avec une patiente une
relation amoureuse quand on est dans un
état amoureux on est dans un état second
et on perd toute concentration et tout
introspection par rapport à soi par
rapport à ces motivations réelles pour
pouvoir vous soigner et d'autre part
nous sommes très très défavorables à ce
que les couples se forment à l'intérieur
de l'établissement et ensuite
s'établissent parce que nous nous avons
ensuite les retours et le retour sont
généralement catastrophiques et la
sanction tombe cette dame là va rester
parce que les
lieux de soins pour les dames sont quand
même plus rares mais vous
moi je pense que il faut que vous ayez
vous soigner dans un autre établissement
après votre devenir à vous deux vous
appartiendra
je préférerais rester ici si vous voulez
je ne j'arrête tout je dis à
Mademoiselle à Madame Gorée c'est fini
et je reprendrai un terme à cette
relation après je j'arrête tout là avec
Madame Gorée parce que je peux j'ai ma
famille qui est près d'ici donc voilà je
mets un terme à ma relation avec madame
je pense pas que ça soit quelque chose
de possible je pense que ça soit pas
quelque chose que ce soit possible c'est
pas quelque chose acceptable
le docteur Husson a tranché Frédéric
devra se soigner loin d'Isabelle
mais bon c'est vrai que c'est la façon
dont ça c'est fait on a trouvé ça un
petit peu voilà pas très logique pas
très sympa je pense que il y a d'autres
façons de faire c'est le principe
si vous voulez mais bon le but c'est
qu'individuellement vous en sortir
ça de toute façon c'est notre première
objectif donc voilà le fait qu'on soit
rencontré après on pourra concrétiser
plus tard
et tout aille bien après il y a pas de
raison
sur ce on va aller manger
Frédéric va faire ses valises un autre
malade va le remplacer car à Louis
Sevestre les lignes ne restent pas vite
très longtemps
Christine va m'aider à comprendre les
critères de sélection des patients
ce matin elle m'invite à participer à
une réunion confidentielle avec le
médecin chef de l'établissement bonjour
[Musique]
vous recevez des membres
sont des gens qui se sont adressés par
des confrères médecins ou qui vous
contactent individuellement il faut
automatiquement que le dossier soit
validé par un médecin d'accord
et une partie aussi administrative
importante et sociale également
importante
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle la commission
d'admission je vous laisse faire
juste à vérifier dans leur dossier les
candidats doivent rédiger une lettre de
motivation
on prend le temps de les lire aussi
parce que du coup on a quand même des
éléments importants
explique un petit peu son chemin où il
en est je sollicite au plus vite
monsieur une place au sein de votre
établissement afin de me rendre plus
résistant à la tentation de boire
belle écriture on essaye de faire en
sorte de les accepter le plus rapidement
possible certes mais il faut surtout que
le patient et se déclic aussi de vouloir
venir parce qu'effectivement quand ils
en arrivent à faire ce dossier là
il faut qu'il y ait vraiment une
motivation derrière et un déclic de
prise en charge d'hospitalisation
peu de candidatures sont rejetées à
peine une vingtaine par an sur un
millier de demandes dans ces cases
extrêmes le patient est réorienté vers
un autre établissement
quelqu'un qui est malade de l'alcool
aujourd'hui en France il peut pas dire
il y a pas de structure pour
m'accueillir c'est vrai parce que c'est
un problème personnel qui est pris en
charge par la collectivité oui bien sûr
quand un passionné sa famille est
touchée son environnement professionnel
voilà un louis Sevestre le nombre de
cure n'est pas limité un malade peut
revenir autant de fois que nécessaire
mais cela a un coût c'est que ça coûte
cher
et c'est dispositif alors pour nous pour
nous le prime journée 12000 euros pour
les trois mois 12000 euros voilà
donc il y aura certainement un retour de
bâton faut pas faire de l'usuasion il y
a un moment donné il y a eu un
développement des structures on se
réjouit mais par contre nous on défend
on défend beaucoup le fait que les
patients qu'on reçoit chez nous sont un
stade de leur maladie qui nécessitent
une prise en charge comme la nôtre et
que on ne pourrait pas soigner ce type
de patient en ambulatoire ni même
après les soins médicaux après les
activités manuelles
etiennent me fait découvrir le troisième
pilier d'une cure de désintoxication
le groupe de parole aujourd'hui l'anime
un de ses ateliers
[Musique]
donc aujourd'hui comme tous les jeudis
matin groupe d'ateliers hebdomadaires
donc au moment entre nous des personnes
de l'atelier aujourd'hui ça va être un
petit exercice
que j'aime bien un mot à tirer
et après c'est à vous de dire ce que ça
vous évoque ça marche
Didier
satisfaction qu'est-ce que ça t'évoque
bah j'ai parlé au présent parce que je
suis pour l'instant je suis satisfait de
du tournure que prend mal de la tournure
je trouve que j'ai voulu dans le bon
sens et puis c'est ce qu'on dit aussi
quoi que ça avance de façon relativement
positive
c'est par de simples jeux que les
malades trouvent enfin les mots
parce que par rapport à l'alcool
et tout ça
m'a fait beaucoup de mal
à moi et à ma famille
parce que j'étais violent sur mes
parents
j'ai perdu ma mère
ça fait deux ans
après je me suis remis à boire à boire
et après bah c'était bon
problème judiciaire
la prison
et là maintenant que je suis revenu ici
au centre de la Membrolle pour une
deuxième cure j'essaie de m'en sortir au
plus
comment dire au mieux comme là je suis
venu pour faire des soins j'ai fait en
même temps
pour faire des cours de rattrapage en
lecture en écriture
qui va m'aider et
après je vais voir on va faire à mesure
finir ma vie
sans alcool
voilà
on t'a vu au début peut-être un peu plus
fermé et puis maintenant
beaucoup plus à rigoler et tout ça fait
vraiment plaisir de parler
merci Sébastien
il nous reste de personnes amélioration
amélioration
l'amélioration donc
là je vois pas
qui s'améliorent est-ce que tu tends
vers une amélioration beaucoup des
marnatures donc j'ai pas encore assez de
recul par rapport moral est-ce que
le but de mature c'est que c'est que le
moral vaille mieux et pour le moment
donc il va pas bien
on va voilà on va terminer sur ça pour
aujourd'hui merci merci
[Musique]
après le groupe de parole j'enchaîne
avec l'atelier à bord extérieur qui
consiste à ramasser les mégots
j'y retrouve Christophe et son mal-être
alors là on arrive sur le plus gros du
chantier et ça
je sais pas si vous allez y arriver
[Applaudissements]
des gens qui prennent pas des
médicaments
mais bon il faut être prêt pour être ici
je suis venu moi il y a 9 ans ici ah
c'est ton deuxième c'est
arrivé à 10h30 à 16h je vais faire
partie
trop
pas prêt
bon je sortais de d'un carcération donc
on sevrage était fait
et bon bah pourquoi venir ici je tente
le sevrage est fait j'en attends
beaucoup de cette
arrivée ici en me disant que j'allais
pas mentir pour une fois je l'ai
je vais venir jouer sans fil
[Musique]
pendant deux ans je me suis jamais
autant alcoolisé pendant pendant mes
soins et les docteurs et tout ça non
rien vu que du feu
la veille hors caméra Christophe m'a
fait une terrible confidence une enfant
de sa famille aurait été agressée
sexuellement par un de ses proches
depuis qu'elle sait que je sais elle me
voit gourer tous les jours
peut-être qu'à aussi coupable non en
revanche que certains c'est que ça te
met une responsabilité terrible c'est si
tu veux vraiment gérer reste à faire tu
n'as pas le droit de boire on peut en
prendre plein la gueule on peut souffrir
on peut être un enfant massacré si on
trouve des adultes sur lesquels c'est ça
qui est super important on a besoin de
quelqu'un à qui s'accrocher quand on est
traumatisé on a besoin de quelqu'un de
solide
il est là
non mais sérieux
ça sera dur mais elle peut absolument
s'en remettre
Christophe a encore deux mois et demi
pour se débarrasser de l'alcool ensuite
il lui faudra apprendre à vivre avec sa
douleur
pour tous ces cabossés de la vie la
reconstruction passe aussi par une
remise en forme
Etienne que j'avais rencontré quand il
animait un groupe de parole encadre cet
après-midi une marche lente
toutes les personnes qui sont présentées
qui vont faire la marche avec nous
aujourd'hui et on est sur une marche
lente donc on marche
lentement on est parti
pour trois heures maximum
la maladie les a fait se refermer
soi-même
grâce à cette simple promenade dans les
bois les patients redécouvrent les
vertus de l'effort physique
sont dans un état quand même physique et
on voit quoi au début ils sont partis un
peu flamboyante petit à petit ça freine
après les mecs ça commence à peiner quoi
c'est toujours ça c'est toujours le
décalage qu'ils ont entre les
représentations de ski pensent être
ils pensent qu'ils peuvent faire plus
spécifiquement voulu travailler dans ce
milieu là tu aurais pu aller ailleurs
moi je m'étais orienté sur le le
professeur de PS au départ je me suis
rendu compte que j'avais pas cette
dimension de soutien d'utilité qui
[Musique]
je suis surpris de voir ce groupe
d'adultes se laisser guider comme une
colonie de vacances
c'est parti et on prend à droite après
prends le petit centimètre infantilisant
dans ce truc là ce côté quand dado en
vacances moi comme adulte je pourrai pas
faire ce qu'ils font et ils ont l'air de
tout accepter je me dis que c'est la
preuve du fait qu'il s'abandonne
vachement à la structure quoi et que
ils font ce qu'on leur dit
j'ai aimé cet endroit ces gens qui se
battent et ceux qui les aident à se
relever
il est temps pour moi de repartir à la
découverte de nouveaux horizons ou
m'attendent d'autres hommes d'autres
femmes aux vies exceptionnelles
[Musique]